Driving through a building looks awesome.
In reality, though, tankers
hate going through buildings.
In one word, it's basements.
Greetings, all. I'm Nicholas Moran.
I commissioned as an
armor officer on M1 tanks
and then M3 Bradleys.
These days, I work as a civilian historian
for the publisher of World of Tanks.
Today, we're going to be
looking at tank battle scenes
in movies and television
and judging how real they are.
This is absolutely correct.
There's gun crews on
each side of the sponson.
The tank is based off of a
Mark VIII "International,"
which was a very late World War I tank
built by both the UK and US.
And at the time, British
tanks, the heavy tanks,
had what were called sponson guns,
the turret that wasn't on the Mark VIII.
[shouting instructions]
Shouting instructions to
each other wouldn't happen.
It's too loud.
Inside a World War I tank,
the entire middle of that tank
was taken up by the engine.
It was massive noise.
What he's doing there,
he's using hand signals.
That's the only way to communicate
inside a World War I tank.
Firing a gun with anything
in the barrel is bad.
You run the risk of
exactly what happened here.
It's called petaling,
when the gun barrel just
petals out like a flower.
And your gun is done.
Oftentimes, you'll see a tank will have
a rubber muzzle cap on the end,
purely to stop any dirt at
all from getting into it.
And it's designed that you can actually
shoot through the muzzle cap.
To my knowledge, on-tank fighting
has never been trained in any army.
Personally, I'd have just
stuck my head out the top,
used a pistol. But,
again, not very dramatic,
and it would kind of suck for Indy.
I would have to give this scene maybe a 3
on feasibility grounds.
A Tiger has appeared on the scene.
Tiger had a mythical
status in World War II.
It had the reputation because
it was very, very hard to kill
and because it had a heck of a gun.
The 8.8 centimeter was lethal
to basically everything.
The problem was that it looks
very much like a Panzer IV,
which was a lot more common.
In actuality, historians
have found very few times
on the Western front
that American soldiers
ever actually met a Tiger.
But for the purposes of
drama, a Tiger is fine.
This was pretty realistic.
Drivers are absolutely
blind inside their tanks,
and they're utterly reliant
on instructions from the commander.
So, that's how you would
get up close to a tank.
Low, below the line of vision,
below the level of depression
that the guns can aim at you.
We're going for the wheels.
Because the Tiger was a breakthrough tank,
it was heavily armored everywhere.
And if you are infantry
and you don't have high-velocity cannons,
your best bet is to disable the tank
and get what's called a mobility kill
to immobilize the tank.
Your two choices are going to be either
the engine compartment
or the running gear.
And the only thing that these sticky bombs
are going to have any particular effect on
will be the running gear.
So, the sticky bomb, it was in the manual,
but it is also almost a
weapon of desperation.
The military is supposed to
give you tools for the job.
Late World War II era, you're
talking about the bazooka.
Now, the problem is that
you only have so many rounds
of bazooka ammunition,
and a bazooka is only so
effective against something
as heavily armored as a Tiger.
So you're in desperation
mode to start with.
Soldier: Both sides, get aboard!
Get a grenade!
So, now we see one of the problems
with a tank going on its own.
A tank shouldn't go on its
own for several reasons.
But when you have infantry,
an infestation, we might
like to say as tankers,
crawling on your tank, there's a process
that's called "scratching
your friend's back."
What you do is you get on the radio,
you call your buddy with a machine gun,
and he will machine-gun your tank.
Of course, the bullets aren't
going to affect your tank.
You're in a tank. But it
will very much clean off
or delouse the infantry that
are crawling on your tank.
And that's your example of delousing.
So, the 20-millimeter anti-aircraft gun,
like any anti-aircraft gun
with a high rate of fire,
you aim that thing horizontally
and you will do a number on infantry.
If there's any big myth about tanks,
it's probably that they are
these invulnerable fortresses.
In reality, they're not
invulnerable at all,
and they're absolutely reliant
on the other parts of
the combined arms team.
You have the desperation
of lightly armed infantry.
You have this back-scratching.
You have the immobilization
of a very dangerous tank.
I mean, this is easily on the 9 scale.
And that is absolutely accurate.
The vast majority of
tanks that were destroyed
had no idea that the enemy was there.
And, again, this is why you always
have to work in conjunction with infantry,
because they have more eyes than you do.
They have better vision than you do.
But more often than not,
the first indication
that somebody is there
is when you get shot at.
And knocking off either
the first or the last tank
in an ambush in a row
like that is classic.
What the f--- was it?
That was an 88. It's a goddamn tank.
With regard to the TCs in this case
keeping their heads out,
there are two schools of thought.
But certainly in the time
period of World War II
all the way through the
Cold War, even myself,
it would be in a head-out position.
The Western school of thought
is you keep your head out
because what you don't see will kill you.
The other school of thought,
such as used by the Soviet
Army in the Cold War,
was that you wanted to operate head-down.
So you close the hatch,
no artillery could affect you,
no snipers could affect you.
And the problem, of
course, is the reverse.
You aren't able to see
whatever is about to kill you.
So there is a balance to be struck.
All right, all tanks, move forward.
Wardaddy has decided for some reason
that he's going to charge the enemy tank.
I'm not sure I would've
done quite the same thing,
because that simplifies
the problem for the enemy
and just gives them
three targets in a line.
If you can have what's
called a base of fire
and then a maneuver element,
then the enemy tank has a choice.
It can engage the guy
that's just sitting there
pumping accurate shots at you,
or the German tank can
engage the flanking element,
who are coming around the side.
And the 76-millimeter
gun on two of these tanks
actually would destroy a Tiger.
OK, so, being obscured,
the German tank has decided
to advance out of the smoke
as opposed to just sit there
and wait for whatever the
enemy were going to do.
The Germans were very, very
big on individual initiative.
The concept is called auftragstaktik.
These days, we use a development of it
called mission command.
But the bottom line is
you don't wait for orders.
You take the initiative. You
make a decision on the spot.
And that is exactly what
the German has done here.
Wardaddy: Bible, put it up his
a-- while the armor's thin.
I know it'll f---ing hit him!
The reticle is accurate for
a World War II American tank,
and Shia, in this case, is
using the coaxial telescope.
So you're going to see
graduations on the reticle.
Each graduation is for a type
of round at a certain range.
So if your target is,
let's say, 800 yards,
you will elevate the gun so
that the 800-yard graduation
is on the target.
So, the single biggest cause
of missing in World War II
was range-estimation error.
If you get the range wrong,
it doesn't matter if your aim is correct,
you will go over or short,
which is why we now have
modern fire-control systems
to do all that mathematics for you.
Again!
On the way!
If you are in this sort of a knife fight,
which I wouldn't recommend getting into,
the first round set the engine alight,
but that doesn't necessarily say
that the tank crew in the turret
can't still get a shot off.
They say you shoot at
a tank until it burns
or changes shape.
So keep shooting until you
know that the threat is gone.
This scene is an easy 9.
What "Fury" lacks in perhaps
some of the technical accuracy,
it more than makes up for in understanding
the experience of being a tank crewman.
Tanks don't go from 0
to 60 just like that.
They're not sports cars.
But they look a lot faster
than they're actually going.
By way of comparison,
the M1 will do 0 to 20 miles an hour
in somewhere over seven seconds.
So to be launched like that,
you are relying a lot on the
momentum of the truck itself.
But, hey, it's a 60-something-ton tank.
It has a lot of momentum.
This is obviously a derivative
of some sort of futuristic tank.
In reality, it's a 1960s
Chieftain that they've dressed up.
But one of the problems
you see with this tank
is you have the big glass
windows for the driver.
In reality, you don't want
to have big glass windows
on a tank, because it's a weak spot.
Guys, we gotta come up with another plan.
They got a tank.
If the opposition comes up with a tank
and you don't have anything
that's an antitank weapon,
yes, you are in a serious problem.
All you can do is try
to be faster than it,
evade it, move to where it can't see you.
If it can see you, it
can probably shoot you.
The tank is not going to slow down
because of the massive recoil of the gun.
Modern tanks have what's
called stabilization,
and what it's designed to do
is to keep the gun on target.
So, with this in mind,
tanks are now very capable
of firing on the move.
My initial thought is to
give it something like a 3,
because, yes, tanks are scary,
tanks will run over anything
that they come across,
but the general concept
of this high-speed chase
is just not there.
So, that's Pierce sticking his head out
a little bit too much.
If you're trying to drive a tank,
remember, you do have pedals,
or usually the brake or the accelerator,
and you've got to be able to
be low enough to reach them.
So, a tank driver's seat has
two positions, up or down.
So head out when you are not in combat,
when nobody's shooting at you.
You can see a lot better.
Because when you're driving
head-down with the hatch closed,
through a little periscope,
it's very easy to miss things,
and you run over people that
you don't want to run over.
The very, very latest tanks do
have cameras rotated around,
but oftentimes they don't.
Tanks are actually very,
very easy to drive.
So, inherently, a tank is designed
to be as simple as possible to operate,
especially for a Soviet tank.
If you can drive a car, you
can basically drive a tank.
Some pretty cool drifting there.
If you are going to drift in a tank,
you either want ice or
you want a Soviet track.
So, there are two types of track
you can get on a tank, generally speaking:
rubber track or all-steel track.
And Soviet tanks tended to
go with an all-steel system.
Although the metal grousers are great
for digging into dirt and mud
and getting you some excellent
cross-country traction,
on a road, there's very
little contact area
between the track and the tarmacadam.
So what you're doing
is you're just sliding,
quite literally sliding around.
So that drifting was kind of fortunate
that they had a Soviet tank doing this.
So, a tank driving through
a building looks awesome.
In reality, though, tankers
hate going through buildings.
If there's any one reason
that tankers hate going through buildings,
in one word, it's basements.
Because if you think about it,
your typical house structure
is not designed to hold the weight
of a 40-something-ton
vehicle above a basement.
And oftentimes, there is no indication
before you drive through the building
whether or not there
is a basement under you
or solid ground.
In this case, it would appear
that he has gotten lucky.
I would probably put it
down more on the 5 area.
He is in a vehicle.
All right, it's a black ...
tank.
The definition of what is
a tank is somewhat debated.
The traditional definition
often revolves around the
physical characteristics.
It's going to have tracks,
it's going to have a gun,
it's going to have a turret,
and it's going to have armor.
But that could also be used to describe
a self-propelled artillery piece.
It could be used to describe
an infantry fighting vehicle.
And it cannot be used to
describe the very first tanks,
which had no turret, or the
S-tank, the Swedish tank,
which also had no turret.
So, these days, you're probably better off
defining a tank by its role.
It's a way of getting a gun from A to B,
and it's very difficult to kill.
So, the Tumbler here at
least has armor and mobility.
Oh, it does have a gun, OK.
I see absolutely no practical reason why
he needs to move to a
new driver's position
in order to operate this
feature of the vehicle.
Having the room inside this vehicle
to move from one position
to an entirely new position,
it's bad design, because you want to have,
that empty space needs
to be protected by armor.
That larger amount of armor weighs more.
And that gives you flotation problems,
emphasizing the problem you
have now on a wheeled vehicle
of this extra weight coming
down on a set of wheels.
Wheeled vehicles don't have
the advantage of the tracks.
You spread the weight of a 60-odd-ton tank
onto a piece of dirt or mud
that it doesn't sink into it.
We do have an impression perhaps
as to just how light this vehicle is,
because he is now driving on a roof.
Roofs are not usually designed
to hold armored vehicles
on top of them,
which also means all this vehicle will do
is stop perhaps machine-gun rounds,
and it's not going to stop
a rocket-propelled grenade
or an antitank round. As
for the vehicle itself,
I don't think that there
is any actual equivalent
in military service around the world.
The closest might be
for something like a
reconnaissance vehicle.
So, there is a vehicle called the Fennek,
and that is, in appearance, very similar.
It's sort of an angled four-by-four,
and it's designed to be fairly fast,
fairly low-profile,
to sneak around the battlefield
and do reconnaissance.
For what it is, I'll give it a 7.
The tanks that they're using
are also very good vismods,
a visual modification.
What we have here is an earlier version
of today's American tank, the M1 Abrams,
and it's basically the
version that I was on
when I was in Iraq.
For a moment, I was in
disbelief that they had used
actual M1s, because the
M1 has a jet engine.
It has an extremely distinctive sound.
[engine whirring]
And in this movie, you
hear the engine starting,
and the sound designers
put in the turbine engine,
and that was enough pause that
you realize, are they Abrams?
So what they've done is they've
taken British Centurions,
they've made it into an M1.
So, real tanks don't drive that close.
You're going to have 100 or
200 yards in between tanks,
because if you're that
close, you make yourself
a perfect target for artillery or aircraft
or anything else with a blast radius.
Why give the enemy an easy shot?
The idea of this battle happening at night
is absolutely in line with
American doctrine of the time.
Set in the 1991 Gulf War,
commonly known as Desert Storm.
The US in particular owned the night.
With modern night-vision gear,
it cannot be understated the advantage
that these pieces of equipment
would give over their enemy,
who could not see or fight at night.
The most famous of the
'91 battles like this
was called 73 Easting.
A swarm of tanks coming at you,
firing on the move, at night.
You can't see them.
All you know is that there is explosions
and your own tanks are blowing up.
And it was absolute textbook shock attack,
and it has become one of
the most famous battles
in US Armor Branch history ever since.
So, what he's holding there is,
I believe it's a PVS-7.
It's an earlier version
of an image intensifier
that we'd use even today.
On these earlier M1 tanks,
the commander's handheld vision
is not as good as a thermal imager.
All right, baby.
Hold on, son. They got no range.
The commander has dropped down.
He's now looking through what's called
the gunner's primary sight extension,
and this allows him to see
exactly what the gunner is looking at.
Calm down. Calm down, son.
Find me another target.
Loaded.
- Identify.
- Up!
- Fire!
- On the way.
So, the coordination in here
is perfectly reasonable.
The crew of the M1 is the driver, loader,
gunner, and commander.
The commander confirms the target.
He gives the fire command.
The loader loads the round,
arms the gun, yells "up."
He keeps back out of the way
because he doesn't want
to get hit by that 120
as it comes back to him.
Cease fire, cease fire.
It's absolutely reasonable
that there would've been
personnel outside of the hatches
shooting machine guns if
they had to get that close.
Now, ordinarily, you wouldn't
want to get that close.
You'd actually stop, and
you will let the infantry
that you were supposed
to be operating with,
the last 100 yards,
while the tanks provide
the overwatching support.
Fire!
You just lit up a friendly.
I heard you. We -- what?
Oh, my God.
You just lit up Boylar, godd--- it!
So, he has just fired and
engaged a friendly tank.
It's called, in army
speak, a blue on blue.
Now, friendly fire has been a problem
since day one of ranged combat.
The problem that you had with the M1,
especially with the early thermal imagers,
was that it was much, much
better at spotting targets
than it was at identifying them.
And at a long range or
if surrounded by fire,
such as it is here,
you didn't always know for sure
what it was that you were engaging.
And the other problem
is that friendly fire
has become a lot more of a thing.
Because recent combat
has been so lopsided,
that if the enemy kills one
of your guys, you know it.
They will have to live with the effects
of they have just killed their friends,
which is exactly the
premise of the movie here.
So, I'd have to give them a 9.
Overall, the tank battle scene
in "Courage Under Fire" are excellent.
Let's go.
All right, move on.
Every tanker I know wants
to be Oddball secretly,
and I'm guilty of that too.
We tried hooking up a
loudspeaker to our tank once
to play music. It didn't
work out, unfortunately.
Oddball: Fire.
OK, so Oddball has fired a paint round.
Such things do not exist,
but Oddball is Oddball.
What he has done, though,
given the situation that
Kelly and Oddball were in,
that's pretty much how I'd do it.
If you're going to shoot at a Tiger,
the rear is the place
you're going to do it.
If I was the German tanker,
I probably would not
have gone down this road
in the first place.
Tanks rule in open area like deserts.
In urban areas and in dense
forests, infantry rule,
and this is part of the reason why.
Since you can't see the
corners like you can in a car,
you are reliant on somebody on the outside
telling you which way to go forwards,
backwards, left, or right.
This is a sort of situation
where you need infantry.
Subject to minor details,
like a tank which fires paint rounds,
has a large loudspeaker on the side
to play morale-boosting music,
that's actually a pretty good scene.
So I'd give that maybe an 8.
Another mandatory movie for tankers.
My favorite tank movie? Well ...
very, very difficult, because
it's a three-way fight.
Two of them we've seen here:
"Fury" and "Kelly's Heroes."
The third one that I'd
call out is "The Beast,"
which is from the 1980s.
It's about a Soviet tank
crew lost in Afghanistan.
Thanks for watching.
If you enjoyed this, why not
click on the video above?